hi i'm beryl and i'm a guest on
buzzfeed's channel hi today i'm going to
be making
one of the first sandwich recipes ever
published
in an american cookbook and it's pretty
interesting the recipe is actually from
this book
the virginia housewife by mary randolph
this is america's first published
regional cookbook and it came out in
1824.
i mean not this one obviously this is a
reprint
in this book you'll find all the hits
like
how to grill a calves head
how to broil and roast a shad
what's a shad
oh it's a fish similar to a herring
how to make a nice biscuit not a mean
one
a nice one but on page 69
is the recipe that we are looking for
oyster loaves
just to let you know mary randolph it
seems adapted this oyster loaf
recipe from an earlier published recipe
in england from a book called the ladies
assistant
i'm interested in mary randolph's
version because it is the precursor to
the modern day
oyster po boy so historical recipes
let's do it there's not
exactly a recipe to follow but it seems
like i need oysters
cream butter and bread so we're just
gonna
open up the oysters oh wait
oh my god
[Music]
i did it and according to the recipe i
need to take a little
round loaf of bread that's what this is
i'm gonna cut off the top and scoop out
all of the crumbs
kind of like i'm making a bread bowl but
not entirely a bread bowl
next i'm gonna put the oysters into a
stew pan with the crumbs
that came out of the loaves i'm adding
some water and a good
some of butter how much is a sum of
butter i'm gonna cook them for about 10
to 15 minutes
and then i'm going to put a spoonful of
good cream
i love these adjectives once it's cooked
we're just gonna fill the loaves we're
going to put a little bit of the
breadcrumbs on top and put them in the
oven to crisp up
and there it is
a historical 1824 oyster loaf
i have no idea how this is gonna taste
[Music]
um if i was gonna rate my confidence
level right now in this
it would be five because it doesn't look
terrible but
i don't know my first historical recipe
it's gonna
oh god we do not have structural
integrity here
this actually tastes pretty freaking
good i feel like maybe it needs a little
salt
i just got a little salt
it looked terrible talk about an
unappetizing cooking process
but in retrospect what i'm eating is
like butter and cream with oysters so
like
why wouldn't it be good i'm gonna try to
eat it like
a sandwich oh
that felt wrong i like it
i was reading a little bit more about it
you know people would like stop off at
inns and be like hey
i need something quick i'm heading to
the next town and they'd be like sure
would you like an oyster loaf
and people would be like yeah so this is
kind of like a
the equivalent of like getting doritos
at the gas station i don't think i
necessarily executed all of this
correctly i imagine now i definitely
needed a smaller loaf it technically did
say
little round loaves final thoughts are
i think this actually was delicious
probably will never make it again
but you never know i do think though i
kind of want to try this again
because it was really fun to do but
that's about it
thank you so much and i will see you
guys later
you